on tuesday 1st march took part in a
humanitarian expedition with three buses that
left from udine in the north east
of italy towards the border between ukraine and poland on the polish side our goal on the initiative of the ukrainian association friuli was to bring
refugees to italy  Ukrainians who
had just crossed the border
I told about this journey as a
journalist but obviously having
found myself in that situation I did everything I could
to give a hand in my small way
for example at the end of this long
journey two nights out of three spent on the
bus
accompanied a family of three
mother with two children to trieste
the bus had finished its journey in
udine an hour's journey in which although
there were several
communication problems because we didn't speak the
same language or we didn't speak languages ​​and
municipalities I was able  to see their
emotion in finally finding a
safe place in looking at the mountains in
looking at the sea  or who had never
succeeded and from the Ukraine could not
finally find a smile fleeing
the war